are things in place now like
um you know code of conduct sort of
anti-harassment workshops you know
workshops that are for the whole cast
and for the whole crew that talk about
what is expected on set in terms of
behavior that never existed before
um intimacy coordinators
um which is so crucial and you know we
did this for a long time before that was
a thing and it's still sort of shocking
to look back and think so much you know
that that was never in place before it
just seems like such an obvious need on
a film set
um so that's different
um and generally yeah I think there is a
there's just a sort of I think also
you're starting to see the way that it's
coming into screenwriting the way that
you know female characters are being
written the way that female characters
are described in screenplays now it's
not perfect but there's definitely
there's a big shift from
you know gorgeous girl in bikini
beautiful but she doesn't know it you
know they're seeing you're seeing
markedly less of that